hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to subnautica now
there's been another major update to the
game since the last time that it played
and it actually involves a lot of
different things ah but first off the
names as usual the first one goes to Dar
Sheeta Chopra who suggested the name
tiny boat Tim and tiny seemeth Tim for
the seamoth it's gonna happen but there
was also another person that suggested
the name tiny bubble Tim I'm kind of
kind of keen on that one and then the
next one goes to shuffle puck who has an
amazing name and he or she said I think
your red hair is pissing all the fish
off that's why they're attacking you
just like how Bulls are attracted to red
and I don't know how true that may be
but I think it's just because I'm a
human in the middle of an ocean an alien
ocean as a matter of fact and they keep
adding updates of the game that adds
more horrifying creatures because in
this particular one called the power nap
update they added beds battery chargers
power cell chargers and horrifying
monsters last one goes to dr. derf who
said that's what you get for cheating
now I don't know what he's referring to
exactly he or she but I didn't cheat I
did not cheat I've been doing it very
very nicely I haven't had any cheating
happening at all anyway
so there's a lot of updates that have
made to the game battery charges Power
Cell charges beds which I don't know
what that means if you can take a nap
but I haven't even found the bed
blueprint I actually went around and I
tried to find a lot of blueprints I did
get if I look up here I got the battery
charger and I have the power cell
charger and it looks like they take
pretty identical things and I have the
majority of these I'm pretty sure so I'm
gonna whip up the necessary stuff to be
able to make one of these right off the
bat and hopefully I'll be able to show
you guys something new almost
immediately wouldn't that be wonderful
wait was that copper wire it needed [ __ ]
okay good and then glass all this basic
crap that we've gone through a million
times I'm gonna make the battery charger
first because I've made I haven't
exactly made Power Cells and I don't
need them just yet but definitely need
the battery charger because that means
God it means finally I wouldn't have to
waste this stupid crap over and over and
over again endlessly wasting this
same amount of batteries having to make
him over and over again and I gotta go
get table coral god damn it Dan endless
struggle for coral yeah [ __ ] it I'll
take the seamoth out I'm gonna put you
in the moon pool eventually did I build
a moon pool
I've got built a moon pool yet god damn
and I'm so far behind on everything I
don't even remember where I left off in
the last episode all I remembered is
that there was a new update that I had
to get through and I gotta explore the
goddamn ocean where is my goddamn silver
there it is thank you okay so this make
the computer chip I just need a bit more
titanium and then walla walla bing bong
we got a battery charger hot damn I
thought there's gonna be faster than
Apple pears very slow but with this
finally I can take the used battery that
I have here and you can charge up to
four at once and of course it takes
power from your building but apparently
not that much power that is amazing Oh
finally I won't have to charge I won't
have to make a new one every single time
oh man that's recycling that's caring
about the environment that is dutifully
making sure that everything in the
surrounding area is gonna be a-okay for
you and now there is a Power Cell
charger then when I need Power Cells
that'll be important but that goes
primarily in the Cyclops because the
Cyclops runs off of six I believe six
Power Cells so you need one in there and
then you need a nuclear reactor in your
Cyclops and then hopefully the Cyclops
has been beefed up enough such that it's
good now I don't know about that but I'm
hoping that so anyway the next thing
that I'm gonna be doing is I am going to
be going to oh [ __ ] okay you just play
your didgeridoo over there I'll be gone
I'll be back love you Karen
whatever Karen loves two didgeridoos
it's her favorite passion okay so if I
put this on now I'll get I'll use the
rebreather once I'm actually down below
and need it but I'm gonna be exploring
now because I need to find the bed
blueprint that's gonna be my next
objective for this game and then in the
next episode I'll get the Cyclops all
ready for you guys and have that a-okay
on everything that I need there but for
now I need to get a pad because that's
one of the new features and the only
other feature in the last update that I
need as far as I know is probably gonna
be oh that's right I need the Lost River
oh I've totally forgot about that yeah I
need to get the the depth upgrades for
my seamoth number one I need to get the
depth upgrade which is gonna be
important but also I need to find the
Lost River because that's going to be a
very very interesting thing in the
future and that is a crevasse that might
even be the loss for River holy [ __ ]
where am I
yeah I think so because the Lost River
ties into that biome with all the
stringing like horrifyingly disgusting
creatures of the deep but I'm not going
there just yet death is not going to
encroach me until a little bit later but
for now I'm gonna be exploring trying to
find all the lovely things in the
horizon okay so the reason I'm going by
the ship is because I'm not a hundred
percent sure on this one but I imagine
there would be beds in structures that
we as humans have made because that's
important so where else would there be
beds but on the ship or possibly in sea
bases that are abandoned around the
place hello big guy so either I find the
things that are like the broken off
pieces of the ship which might have
something because they have lockers in
there and they might have beds which is
I think that's less likely but the
alternative is that on the ship itself
is the possibility of a bet so I'm gonna
find that out and I'll be back when I
find it yeah
hi you something I can open aha
whoa hello hi anybody home
Oh probably not oh boy
Wow this don't look good oh it looks
like the opposite of good well what was
the point of this sealed door cut open
to access oh god damn it I don't have my
uh I don't have a welder I guess I got
to get that next okay I'll be right back
I'm gonna get then I'm gonna come back
right here because I know it's got
goodies in it and I'm gonna find him
just as soon as I go find crash powder I
will find you someday don't poop on me
please tell me there's something down
here hello
he's anti-party gorgeous blood I
probably shouldn't have brought my CMOS
all the way down here but I don't want
to drown no okay this to the five get to
this out use the laser cutter haha is
this oh there we go
Wow this is gonna take a while this must
be some door I mean holy [ __ ] oh that's
cool oh that's cool
what is blind here I didn't even know
that we were gonna run across this okay
okay all right place your bets and watch
behind the door I'm willing to bet Abed
haha or there could be dead bodies
that's always a possibility because
nighttime just approached and that
probably means the tennyson's of the
deep are gonna rise from their graves ah
oh also owner's option absolutely
nothing ah whoa look at that
bye okay cool we go through here hello
hi I bet there's nothing special is
there Oh God
you are kidding me you are goddamn
kidding me what a load I win god damn it
what the [ __ ] [ __ ] oh that is Ditka
tree ah that is there's nothing it's
empty there is nothing what a load of
[ __ ]
oh what a bag of dicks oh that is such
ass oh [ __ ] oh god damnit wow that was a
big ass waste of everybody's time
okay I guess we're moving on that was
absolutely nothing I was excited for no
reason at all
that wasn't there before is there gonna
be another thing to cut open in here
that's filled with disappointment
probably well let's see I don't even
think I can cut this open Kenna whoa Oh
came out the wrong time there ah good
yes a door that I pretty sure I just
came from Oh Oh build this [ __ ] huh
who's trying to fool me that this is
actually something important to cut
through what a load of a hat I am I'm
pissed I'm legitimately pissed because
now my welder or my laser cutter is half
out of battery there's something down
here
no something up there no something to
there no load of [ __ ] that's what it
is
alright I thought oh I'm disappointing
I'm disappointing because I thought I
was gonna be able to show you guys
something cool that I come across
something interesting in fun
neato we do' and nothing happened god
damn it okay I gotta go back home
it's a [ __ ] and a half but I gotta go
back and waste too much power
well that was a waste of a trip I gotta
build the moonpool that's the number one
thing that I got to do right now because
I can't keep replacing the Power Cell
especially considering I didn't build
the Power Cell recharger so I need to
I'm gonna go back I'm gonna build the
moonpool
I'm gonna build the power silver charger
because I forgot actually you know I
want if I build the moonpool I won't
even need the power celery charger so I
got
do one or the other I don't know I don't
know ooh whoa what is this wait a minute
what the [ __ ] is this
whoa what the sure hey back off a second
there what the [ __ ] is even happening
here what what am I looking at this
doesn't make a lot of sense it's just
kind of all raised up and what off what
[ __ ] is there like something that's not
spawned that's supposed to be here is
this actually like this whatta [ __ ] and
scan this because I want this but whoa
that is bizarre I have a funny feeling
that one of the like an entity didn't
load or something but there is there is
something not right going on here what
the [ __ ]
okay goddamn I really do need to just
like like swim through the entire ocean
because there's a lot of stuff around
here that I do not know like I literally
just don't understand it because I
haven't seen it yet
like I haven't I haven't swam through
the entirety of the newly updated open
ocean like the reason why I started this
new save was so I could get to all this
new terrain data that I just literally
have not seen yet so it's actually gonna
be really cool to be able to go through
it all which I will in time okay so I'm
back home and what I'm gonna do is I'm
going to build the moon pool and that
requires a lot of crap doesn't hurt moon
pool titanium ingot that's not bad
that's just a lot of titanium lubricant
I can get from right over there yeah
okay this thing's so bad I just got to
go get it which means that I gotta get a
lot of titanium fire pile of
he deals really fine in my own way
ah boo boo boo boo ba ba boo boo ba ba
ba ba ba ba ba ba I go a little out of
my mind when I'm farming like literally
I go completely out of my look I go
completely out of my mind but in a good
way right up Willie
ah right there ah yes Stefan yeah yeah
who does ski nice okay so that release
the strengths of it but at least we got
what we need which is good um so now I
just got a doc the seamoth who has seen
better days
we're gonna pop this bad boy in here huh
I wonder what its standing on and then
it's gonna charge up and I'm gonna
freakin get another welder a guess don't
know where the other one but hello oh
that was nice and silent well [ __ ] ha
boink okay ah
nice
Wow
this is like the scariest background
music for an underwater horror movie
that I've ever heard my entire life it's
kind of amazing
I appreciate our winery system our
systems online primary systems online
Wow
what the hell was that I mean I know
exactly what it was but wow that was
terrifying that was like the scariest
thing I've ever had in subnautica I
don't know why subnautica constantly
wants to be a horror game but a horror
game it'd be so that's what we shall be
dealing with okay man all right so
that's all the time I got through this
episode to subnautica sorry I didn't do
as much progress on the new update that
I thought but with my dedication to not
cheating it's harder to make leaps and
bounds than what I used to so we got to
go through a more methodical process so
thank you everybody for being patient
thank you for watching so much and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye bye I'll do my best
oh you're joking
I wanna get in so you got your girl he's
in a cute little outfit that I didn't
handpick cause I'm creepy I'm not creepy
I swear